pour nous faire rire
qu'est ce que les humoristes ont retenu
de 2019 les hauteurs de revue et
corrigée du théâtre du rideau vert
travail sur les textes depuis le mois de
mai cette année c'était l'environnement
le climat c'est ça qui prenait toute la
place
on savait pas encore comprendre regrette
comme personnage parce qu'elle est venue
un petit peu plus tard
[Applaudissements]
je suis la meilleure chose qui soit venu
de suède depuis les petites boules et
mesquer greenberg et l'environnement
sont aussi présents dans la revue salut
présenté au monument national en fait
c'est une revue de presse alors je crois
que nommer un thème on y traite en 50
matches là dedans des dizaines de
chansons
il ya des thèmes incontournables
évidemment c'est la laïcité le retrait
du crucifix michel forgeau fait pour
enlever mon tu vu
vous comprenez pour nom propre besoin
d'argent
rabat est gratuit oui mais c'est quoi
que vous comprenez pas la dame sur la
grille l'équipe de l'émission radio à la
semaine prochaine
travaillent d'arrache-pied pour son
émission spéciale du réveillon
c'est une année électorale ben
intéressant c'est sûr qu'on trouve c'est
ce qu'on va retrouver du vol de données
chez desjardins
c'est sûr qu'on va retrouver un petit
peu de netflix peut-être dans nos
affaires mais il ya aussi peut-être
qu'on élit seul on va parler aussi de la
chine et du porc ccp
enfin on essaie faut pas perdre notre
personnalité de son côté l'équipe du bye
bye protège jalousement les thèmes qui
seront abordés comme la question qui
porte son propore pas on sait même pas
quel jour finir à temps on sait pas qui
a fait ça va être un bon bye bye j'ose
dire quoi défense parle on se dit ah
yoye je pense qu'on a notre meilleur bye
bye puis après ça deux heures après on
se parle
mm ça marche pas pas tout juste à la
montage et rien ne marche
ça va être horrible billets fausses
plaintes herman n'est de toute façon
l'équipe du bye bye peut dormir sur ses
deux oreilles parce que peu importe le
résultat est des gens qui vont crier au
génie et d'autres qui vont détester ici
navire laissant jarty radio canada
montréal